By now, most of you are almost certainly aware
of SCP-343. From the outset, he appears to be an
unassuming old man, although the specific details
of his appearance are subject to change based
on whoever happens to be looking at him. Oh, and
he’s also God; we probably should have opened with
that. Or, at the very least, SCP-343 claims that
he was responsible for creating… well, everything.
Virtually the entire universe as we know and
understand it, and even all of the parts we
can’t even fathom are, according to him,
the result of SCP-343’s design. It’s that
assertion that earned him his nickname of ‘God’
among the staff of the SCP Foundation. Well,
that and the fact that he can seemingly do
anything with as little as a thought. In fact,
SCP-343 doesn’t really even need to think all
that hard to literally rework reality around him.
So, you might be wondering, with virtually
unlimited reality-warping power that can enable
him to do and be anywhere, all the knowledge in
the entire universe, and nothing but free time on
his hands: what exactly to SCP-343 do all day?
6:00 AM
SCP-343 starts most days awake before most
of the Foundation staff at Site 17. Well,
to say he’s awake before is actually
something of a misstatement. Technically,
he can’t be awake before anybody, because he never
really sleeps to begin with. He doesn’t need to,
not only because he doesn’t require sleep to
replenish energy like any mortal being does,
but also due to the fact that SCP-343
doesn’t exactly experience time in much the
same way as human beings do. After all, he did –
supposedly – create the very force of time itself.
Rather than living moment to moment like we do,
experiencing the present, which then becomes
our past, SCP-343 can exist at any and all points
in time at will. For him, the past, present, and
future are occurring simultaneously, although he
seems to stay as closely tethered to the present,
but this is more out of choice.
If he wanted to, we’re sure SCP-343
could be at every moment in history, probably even
in multiple different locations and even timelines
at once. But that’s just what happens when you’re
the apparent original architect of the universe
and don’t rely on ancient numerical systems and
the rotation of the Earth in order to tell time.
After being awake for all of what we
perceive as nighttime, SCP-343 will go for
a stroll around nice and early. Oh, you thought we
meant a stroll around the facility he’s kept at?
No, no, he’ll take a stroll anywhere, literally
phasing through solid matter and sometimes even
just teleporting to whatever place takes his
fancy. Sometimes he’ll just choose a place
at random, or pick an old favorite; just
somewhere scenic to watch the sun rise.
8:00 AM
Once the Foundation’s personnel have had
enough time to both fully wake up and realize that
SCP-343 has wandered out of his quarters, then an
urgent search will undoubtedly be underway.
Panicked Foundation security teams will start
racing through the halls of Site 17, frantically
searching for SCP-343. He’s not exactly trying
to evade them, he’s just naturally very resistant
to being contained. It certainly makes keeping up
with him a challenge, especially when he walks
through walls into the cells of other SCPs.
When the security team find him,
it’s inevitably because alarms are
sounding to alert them that another containment
chamber has been breached. Sometimes, in fact,
more often than not, the staff stationed at SCP
Site 17 will receive word from another Foundation
installation that they’ve just seen SCP-343 stroll
past security at a completely different location.
Sometimes he’ll pay a visit
to SCP-049, the Plague Doctor,
usually casually conversing with the anomalous
physician and admiring his surgical skills.
Handling medical tools is a tricky enough task,
made even harder with a beaky mask on your face.
On other occasions, the Foundation has caught up
with SCP-343 on his morning strolls in various
other facilities, or with a number of different
anomalies. Often, he’ll slip through walls to
spend time with SCP-529, better known as
Josie the Half Cat; an otherwise ordinary
domesticated cat with anomalously intangible
hind quarters. Sometimes SCP-343 will also
pay a morning visit to SCP-999, stating that he
hopes the Tickle Monster will be ‘ready one day’.
Other times, SCP-343 has been found by the
Foundation sitting with Cain, with the pair
usually being in mid-discussion over some deep
philosophical pondering. The pair of them are
rather friendly with each other, as if they’ve
known each other for a while, with SCP-343 on one
occasion even being noted as remarking to Cain:
“It’s so good to see how far you’ve come, my boy,
especially after all that nasty
business with your brother.”
10:00 AM
Wherever he ends up, once the Foundation is
able to catch up with him, they politely ask him
to return to his quarters back at Site 17. SCP-343
is always amicable and will make his way back
post-haste, usually arriving before the security
team who chased him down are able to make it back.
Once he’s back, it doesn’t take SCP-343 long to
get bored, however. So, he decides to undertake
a little bit of home decorating to pass the
time. He’s already conjured a fireplace and
plenty of elegant furniture into his room,
but on this particular day, he feels like
adding some color to brighten the place up.
With little effort, the Mona Lisa, The
Starry Night, The Persistence of Memory,
Café Terrace at Night, and plenty more of the
world’s most famous paintings all simultaneously
appear on the walls. Having summoned so many
famous works to his room, SCP-343 has transformed
his quarters into his own personal art gallery.
He spends a while studying the paintings,
looking at the skillfulness that went into
the creation of each one. Every brush stroke,
every color choice; he almost seems like a proud
father looking at his child’s art on display at a
school open day. SCP-343 finds it oddly humbling,
to see how human artists have reflected just a
fraction of the majestic universe he created, and
all through such simple means. Paint on canvas,
oil and water, brushes, and an easel; they
seem so quaint to someone whose preferred
medium is the very fabric of reality itself.
And yet, so many of the paintings he looks
at seem to show the world through an even more
beautiful lens. Imagination, SCP-343 admired it.
Naturally, when multiple art galleries
around the world reported that some of
their most famous works had all been stolen at
the exact same moment, it didn’t take very long
for that news to reach the Foundation. When
they were eventually able to determine where
the paintings were, a squad of guards politely
told SCP-343 that they needed to be returned.
“We’ve been looking everywhere
for them,” one explained.
With as little as a blink, SCP-343 sent each of
the paintings back to where they had come from.
12:00 PM
At midday, there was a knock
at SCP-343’s door, from notorious high-ranking
Foundation researcher Doctor Jack Bright. Often,
whenever he was working close enough to Site
17, Doctor Bright would pop in to visit SCP-343,
usually bringing along the anomalous reality
warper’s preferred meal: hamburgers. The pair
would chat casually to begin with, enjoying
their food while a pair of security guards
stood watch outside. However, inevitably their
conversation would always take the same turn…
“You could remove it, couldn’t
you?” Doctor Bright asked,
referring to SCP-963, the amulet he wore
around his neck. “Or nullify it somehow?”
The anomalous artifact was bound to Jack
Bright, allowing his consciousness to be
passed from one host body to the next, granting
him functional immortality. Although, over time,
his extended lifespan had felt less and less
like a gift, and more like a curse. SCP-343
had already been aware of this, thanks to them
having the same conversation over a number of
years. He’d known Doctor Bright for longer
than most others working at the Foundation;
and knew how badly the researcher wanted to die.
But every time, SCP-343 would deny Jack’s request.
“Jack, you know I could,” SCP-343 replied.
“But you won’t,” the Foundation doctor
finished the sentence. “Why not?
Will you explain that to me?”
“Because I know why you’re asking.”
“And why am I?” Jack probed further,
calm, not once raising his voice.
“It’s not that you’re tired of being alive
for so long, although that may be how it feels,”
SCP-343 explained. “But you only feel that way
because you’re unfulfilled. You have this gift of
immortality, and what do you use it for? You work,
all you do is work. Just because you no longer
have the short life everyone else doesn’t mean you
should stop living, Jack. You devote yourself to
the Foundation, all its SCPs and horrors. Go out
and do something for yourself every so often. Go
to a party, meet people. Or make something, create
a piece of art. You could even try making a movie.
What’s the worst that could happen? That’s why I
won’t remove the amulet, Jack, because I want
you to have a chance to enjoy your extra time.”
1:30 PM
After finishing
his lunch with Doctor Bright, SCP-343 takes some
time out of his day for recreation. Completely
unbeknownst to the Foundation, SCP-343 phases out
of reality – as we understand it – and enters an
extradimensional space, an astral plane, some
might call it. While there, SCP-343 likes to
enjoy a game of Solitaire, conjuring a deck of
playing cards from nothing and using them to play.
Solitaire is a basic game, and once based
on chance. How easy or difficult it is to
complete rows of cards all in their matching
set, is all down to the random arrangement of
the deck. That could be why SCP-343 likes playing
a game like Solitaire. He has the ability – so he
claims – to create or unmake any part of the
universe, to go anywhere, or to do anything.
If he wanted to, the cards could always be in
the perfect order for him to finish the game
in a few seconds. But where would be the fun?
Most, if not all, of SCP-343’s behavior seems
to imply that – despite his untold levels of
reality-warping power – he enjoys giving up
control. Or at least, the illusion of not having
to control everything around him. Playing with a
completely random deck of cards feels very much
in line with that aspect of his personality.
If SCP-343 wanted to, he could always draw the
right card he needed for his Solitaire games, but
then he would be giving up that illusion of not
having control. In much the same vein, he could
very easily erase the universe’s most dangerous
anomalies, or even destroy the SCP Foundation with
little effort, if he wanted to. And yet, he opts
instead to go through the motions, to let the deck
of cards stay in random order.
4:00 PM
By the time the afternoon is about to
become the evening, there’s normally
a bit of commotion at Site 17, all caused by
SCP-343. Given how large the SCP Foundation is,
and how expansive the organization’s various
facilities and operations are, inevitably,
someone who hasn’t heard about SCP-343 eventually
learns of his existence. When another group
within the Foundation learns that Site 17 is
accommodating a potentially dangerous SCP,
with the ability to warp reality on a completely
unknown scale, it tends to cause a little panic.
Requestioning a Mobile Task Force, a Site
Director from another facility stormed into
Site 17. He demanded to be shown to SCP-343’s
quarters, despite protests from the on-site staff,
who all reassured the Director that there
was nothing to worry about. They had all
worked with SCP-343, all conversed with him,
and knew him to be benevolent. But that just
gave the Site Director more cause for concern.
If SCP-343 could really do anything, surely he
could have influenced how the personnel at Site
17 perceived him, via some cognito hazardous means
that meant they only thought he was harmless.
Bursting into SCP-343’s room with the MTF
troopers, the Site Director demanded that the
powerful reality warper explain himself. By
this point, this had happened enough times that
SCP-343 just used the sudden intrusion as an
excuse to leave the facility again for a while.
He never even acknowledged that the agents from
another part of the Foundation were trying
to confine him, he merely got up and walked
away. Even when the Site Director, who was a
far more trigger-happy one this time around,
commanded his men to open fire, SCP-343 was
unphased. The bullets from the MTF’s weapons
had no effect, melting into nothing practically
the second they exited the barrel of their guns.
Ignoring angered shouts to sit back down
and stay put, SCP-343 casually walked off,
disappearing through a wall and leaving the Site
Director and MTF scrabbling to track down where
he’d gone to now.
7:00 PM
The wider SCP Foundation was thrown into a state
of panic, all while the reassurances of the Site
17 staff fell on deaf ears. It didn’t matter
how many times they said that SCP-343 would
come back in his own time, the Foundation
were already scouring the Earth looking for
the reality-warping old man. Of course, few
people think to look for you when you hide
out in a specific quiet old town in Belgium.
SCP-343 had decided to take a sightseeing tour
of Europe while the SCP Foundation attempted
to track him down. Every time he sensed that
their agents were nearby, he vanished to another
scenic location. He enjoyed being around people;
their lives were so short and fleeting compared
to his, the novelty of spending time walking
among his ‘creations’ never seemed to wear thin.
They spent their lives fretting over concerns that
seemed so trivial to a being who could see
the entire cosmic scope of everything that
existed. And yet, it was these ordinary people
who had built great cities and civilizations,
who had developed culture and art beyond anything
SCP-343 could ever have anticipated when he
created them… if he actually did create them.
His tour across Europe had brought SCP-343
to Bruges, the oldest and most well-preserved
medieval town in Belgium. He stood at the top
of an old clock tower, looking out at the view
of the buildings and the canal that ran through
Bruges. He was impressed at how long a place like
this, made by man, had stood the test of time.
An old man came to join SCP-343, having observed
him in the tower and thinking he looked lonely.
The pair of them got to chatting, the reality
warper revealed who he was; much to the man’s
surprise, he found himself believing the
outlandish claim that this stranger had indeed
made the whole universe. The old man proceeded to
ask about the meaning of life and the universe,
what everything meant and was for.
“Forty-two,” SCP-343 answered smirking,
still staring out over Bruges.
The old man looked confused.
“That’s just a joke from a book I quite enjoyed.”
8:00 PM
SCP-343’s sightseeing break didn’t end in
Belgium. In fact, it didn’t even stay confined
to Earth for very long. The SCP Foundation,
the ones who weren’t stationed at Site 17,
were still on the lookout for the reality-warping
old man, although they were still yet to turn
their gaze upwards. Without any fanfare, nor any
explosive teleportation, SCP-343 just popped into
existence… standing on the surface of the Moon.
He basked in the Earth-light for a while,
looking at the view of the entire world. From
here, it seemed so much smaller, still colossal
in size compared to SCP-343 himself, but it was
the distance. Everything seemed so far away, so
microscopic that for a mortal, it might be hard to
comprehend. But for SCP-343, he could see clearly:
a world teeming with life. He turned his gaze to
the infinite expanse of space, the whole universe
beyond; stars burning against an inky blackness.
As he stood looking out at the solar system,
like someone admiring their handiwork, he
spotted something that surprised even him.
A few million kilometers from the Sun was an
old Volkswagen microbus. This was SCP-1958,
a vehicle that had been heavily modified by
a group of friends so that they could leave
Earth and go travel the cosmos together.
They had initially been successful,
and had planned to visit Alpha Centauri, a
Star System in the Constellation of Centaurus.
Unfortunately, a miscalculation meant it
would take millions of years to reach their
destination. Ultimately, the entire group on
board SCP-1958 had perished, lost in space.
While he was saddened to know of their deaths
– thanks to his omniscience – SCP-343 could
hardly blame the group of young friends for
wanting to travel to the stars. He might not
have chosen to do so in an old microbus,
but he could understand why they would go
to such lengths to fly away from Earth.
It truly was beautiful up here in space,
SCP-343 thought.
10:00 PM
Having decided he’d been gone for long enough,
SCP-343 thought it was about time that he should
be making his way back to Site 17. He’d given the
SCP Foundation enough of a run around for one day.
SCP-343 would finally settle back into the comfort
of his cell – exactly where he wanted to be.
Want an anomaly of your own? Check out
www.scpswag.com for high-quality SCP merch!
Now go check out WHAT IF SCP-343 WORE
SCP-035?” and “SCP-343 GOD VS BILL CIPHER
FROM GRAVITY FALLS” for more explorations
into everyone’s favorite anomalous deity!